bien
[Música]
bienvenidos a directo con 26 el espacio
de france 24 dedicado a entender a
profundidad qué está pasando en la
cumbre climática de la onu en glasgow
allí está nuestra enviado especial de
marina colorado con constantes
actualizaciones de las discusiones y los
acuerdos en proceso marina un saludo
para usted y la agenda de este día se ha
centrado en las posibilidades
energéticas para dejar de lado los
combustibles fósiles y avanzar hacia el
objetivo de cero emisiones para 2050
así desangelada y las negociaciones han
ido avanzando a lo largo del día y el
presidente de la cob 26 a loc sharma el
británico ha dicho que él cree que los
objetivos y los compromisos que se están
escuchando en la cob 26 nos llevan hacia
un buen camino según el el carbón ya no
es el rey aunque eso lo contra belo
contradicen las cifras porque según
datos de 2019 el 37 por ciento de la
producción de energía sigue estando
basada en el carbón sin embargo la
agencia internacional de la energía dijo
que estos compromisos que hemos estado
escuchando a lo largo de la semana de
los que voy a hablar en unos minutos si
nos ponen en camino a que las
temperaturas no aumenten más de 1,9
grados a finales del siglo algo que
estaría alineado con lo que pretende el
acuerdo de parís algunos de estos
compromisos a los que se han llegado
aunque no se ha firmado nada y nada no
hay ningún plan concreto acerca de cómo
se van a llevar a cabo es la reducción
de metano al 30 por ciento antes de 2030
como lo veníamos anunciando desde ayer y
también 21 países han anunciado dejarán
de financiar proyectos basados en el
carbón en territorio extranjero a partir
del año que viene y que invertirán los 8
mil millones de dólares que no están
invirtiendo en proyectos de carbón los
invertirán en proyectos de energías
renovables también 40 países se han
comprometido a no invertir en plantas de
carbón dentro y fuera de su territorio y
que irán cerrando plantas basadas en
este material fósil en 2030 o 2040 para
los países en vías de desarrollo
bueno marina y hablando de energía el
transporte marítimo supone 2,5 por
ciento de las emisiones globales
así es un poquito más que el de la
aviación de hecho y
uno de los pasos más grandes que hay de
transporte marítimo es el canal de
panamá ubicado en el continente
americano que traen por donde transita
el 25 por ciento del comercio mundial
para hablar un poquito acerca de ello me
acompaña alexis rodríguez él es
especialista en protección ambiental del
canal de panamá precisamente bienvenido
a france 24 y le quería preguntar que
están haciendo desde el canal de panamá
para minimizar los impactos ambientales
en las comunidades locales por ejemplo y
para reducir el impacto ambiental y de
emisiones que tiene el transporte
marítimo
buenas tardes justamente el canal de
panamá está trabajando en conjunto con
diversas estrategias
estamos en este momento elaborando dos
estrategias la primera es la de carbono
neutral a la cual nos comprometimos para
el año 2030 y también el plan de
descarbonización al año 2050 no
solamente de las operaciones sino
también en conjunto con la cuenca
hidrográfica del canal de panamá
justamente en esta área es donde indica
por ejemplo que existe las comunidades
que apoyan a los proyectos que trabaja
el canal de panamá teniendo en cuenta
una importancia en nuestra ruta es toda
agua depende del agua también del
ambiente y más importante también la
biodiversidad entonces estamos viendo lo
de un punto de vista holístico como esto
también apoya a todas las acciones del
cambio climático trabajando en conjunto
con la industria marítima internacional
y usted está aquí presente representando
al canal de panamá en la cop 26 que es
tan saliente que está saliendo de las
negociaciones a las que usted a las que
usted ha estado presente o en los
eventos en los que usted ha estado
presente justamente dos aspectos estamos
también como negociadores parte del
panamá el tema marítimo es ha tomado
bastante impulso digamos se han hecho
diversas declaraciones a nivel
internacional en cuanto a la aguja de
ruta de descarbonización teniendo en
cuenta que las decisiones van a ser
tomadas en la organización marítima
internacional si no pero teniendo en
cuenta los objetivos del acuerdo de
parís en este momento nosotros hoy
realizamos una presentación en el action
hope que es uno de los eventos de la
conferencia de cambio climático donde
presentamos
cuáles son los avances de las rutas
sostenibles particularmente como un caso
escrito del canal de panamá y cómo
podemos hacer estos actores trabajar en
conjunto con la industria marítima
internacional el 80 por ciento de las
mercaderías se mueven a través de
embarcaciones pero las embarcaciones no
podrán realizarlo solo tenemos que hacer
toda la cadena de suministro tendrá que
trabajar en conjunto puertos canales y
por supuesto el consumidor final quiénes
somos los que estamos tomando la
decisión de cambiar el rumbo pues
muchísimas gracias alexis rodríguez de
responsable de medio ambiente
especialista en medio ambiente del canal
de panamá para hablar acerca de un
poquito de los de lo que se está
hablando aquí el día hoy el día de hoy
acerca de la energía en la con 26 angela
marina gracias a ustedes y recuerden que
de lunes a sábado a esta misma hora
estamos con ustedes en directo con 26
sigan con nosotros
[Música]